bienvenue à vous tous et merci d'être
avec nous une base militaire ukrainienne
frappé par un bombardement russe des
faits rapportés par les autorités
ukrainiennes la frappe aérienne a visé
un centre international pour le maintien
de la paix de la sécurité à une
quarantaine de kilomètres de lviv huit
missiles tirés sur ce terrain
d'affrontement elle aurait fait au moins
35 morts et 57 blessés selon les
autorités locales bilal tarabet merci
d'être avec nous l armée ukrainienne at
elle encore les moyens d'une défense
aérienne elle a les moyens d'une défense
aérienne et notamment grâce à ces
missiles stinger alors les missiles
stinger ce sont des missiles de
fabrication américaine
l'avantagé c'est qu'ils sont pas chères
à l'achat ils sont pas chères à la
production et surtout on peut les
transporter à dos d'homme alors il faut
imaginer un tube d'une d'une quinzaine
de kilos voilà qu'on transporte sur
l'épaule et ça c'est des missiles qui
verrouille automatiquement leur cible
donc en fait sont très faciles à
utiliser il suffit simplement de fa
simplement dire qu'il suffit de tirer
dans la dans la région où se trouve la
cible qu'elle soit un hélicoptère ou un
avion alors évidemment un avion un peu à
basse altitude 1 par un avion qui vole
dans la stratosphère
mais ce sont des missiles qui font
énormément de dégâts ce sont des
missiles qui font très très peur aux
russes et on a l'équivalent du stinger
mais pour les chars qui s'appelle le
javeline et si je vous dis ça c'est
pourquoi parce que ça explique aussi
comment ces soldats ukrainien arrive à
retenir l'armée russe on a beaucoup d'
images de partisans ukrainien de civils
qui ont pris les armes et avec un
courage on va dire objectif ou
indéniable défendre leur pays mais il ya
aussi l'armée ukrainienne qu'on voit
beaucoup moins et qui est mieux équipée
y compris avec ses missiles alors je
voudrais quand même vous montrer voilà
où se trouve la base de ja vos rides
donc un qui a été qui a été visée on la
voit elle est à une quarantaine de
kilomètres de lviv et elle est à peine
ici à une vingtaine de kilomètres de la
pologne alors qu'est ce que c'est qu'est
ce que cette frappe nous dit dit
finalement plusieurs choses d'abord on
le sait un pendant au moins les dix
premiers jours le conflit ne s'étendait
pas à l'ouest ne s'étendait pas dans
cette partie là de l'ukraine qui est à
la fois un sanctuaire si vous voulez
pour les ukrainiens qui est aussi
historiquement la partie d'ukraine qui
est la plus pro occidentale mais qui est
surtout
frontalière avec des pays de l'union
européenne et de l'otan et en
l'occurrence la pologne qui à peine à 20
km de cette de cette base militaire est
à la fois membre de l'union européenne
est à la fois membre de l'otan et
justement les bombardements se
rapprochent là avec cette frappe des
frontières européennes
cette frappe se rapproche énormément
fait on peut quasiment considéré que
c'est une frappe à la frontière alors
c'est le message des russes c'est quoi
c'est que cette base elle servait aussi
de deux centres d'entraînement conjointe
entre l'armée ukrainienne et ses
partenaires de l'otan cette base servait
actuellement aussi à former des des
combattants étrangers donc ça c'est la
russie qui dit à l'ukraine vos bases y
compris celles qui sont utilisées avec
des militaires qui ne sont pas
ukrainiens nous les viseront ça c'est la
première chose deuxièmement il va
falloir énormément de sang froid de tout
le monde pour que mais finalement des
missiles qui tombent à 20 km du côté
ukrainien de la frontière ne tombe
éventuellement pas à 20 km du côté
polonais de la frontière parce que si ça
arrive c'est donc techniquement une
attaque dans l'union européenne et de
très content membres de l'otan merci
beaucoup bilal tard a day pour votre
analyse mais